[Music]
what hello once again and we greet you
in jesus' name we welcome you to I'd
like to know this is our question and
answer program here at sum TV it is our
privilege and pleasure to join you each
week to take your questions to answer
your questions from the word of God and
we just have a good time doing so my
name is CA Murray I'm in the company of
Pastor Steven bore our president and
founder Pastor as always good to have
you here good to have you aboard it's
always a delight to be with you in this
this program uh we really enjoy doing
research and we enjoy answering the
questions in so far as the Lord has
revealed the answer amen and amen thank
you for that caveat Pastor David Salazar
who uh is the uh general manager of our
Latino Channel doing a fine job Pastor
it's always good to have you here thank
you Pastor it's always a blessing for me
to spend time with both of you and learn
from you guys so praise the Lord for
that and we praise the Lord for that um
some people like opening presents we all
do but we like opening the word of God
and uh studying uh the word of God in
answer to your questions we make you
this promise always that if you will
send in your questions as Pastor bour
just alluded to we will answer them from
the word of God we will try our very
best to find an answer if an answer can
indeed be found and give you that answer
from the word of God in respect to the
time it took you to write and send your
questions we want to spend adequate time
researching and answering your questions
which is why we don't necess necessarily
do this program live because we want to
to do some research for some of your
questions some of the questions are very
very involved very complex and it would
be unfair to you to sort of answer them
off the cuff we like to take a moment or
two to study and then bring you the
digest of that study so that your
question is answered thoroughly and
completely as we can should you want to
send in a question and we implore you to
do so write us at TV atom tv.org that is
TV at some
tv.org that's where you send your
question we'll get to them just as soon
as we can we ask you in advance if you
would just tell us where you're writing
from it doesn't have to be the street or
Village it can be just the country we
want to know where you're writing from
and it gives us some idea of our reach
our footprint where uh we are blessing
others if you would tell us where
they're coming from it is not mandatory
we just ask you to do that as a favor to
us and thank you in advance pastor bore
if you would ask God's blessing we'll
launch out into today's
program let's pray Father in Heaven uh
we know that you have said that the fear
of the Lord is the beginning of wisdom
in other words we can't have any wisdom
apart from you and so at this moment as
we begin this program we ask for divine
Enlightenment amen through the mission
of the Holy Spirit we want to handle
your holy word with care we want to
handle it
correctly I ask that you will guide our
minds our thoughts that we might answer
the questions and the answer will be
helpful to those who ask them as well as
many others and so be with us guide us
and bless us with your presence we pray
in Jesus name amen amen amen amen our
first question comes to us from Robert
and it's
anv I believe or anakah
and um we don't have a location but
thank you for sending in your question
brother Robert um he says good day
pastors I wanted to get your thoughts on
the prophetic 7,000 years wouldn't we be
at the tail end today now we've taken a
question sort of like this that dealt
with Ellen White's mentioning the 6,000
years and so I think this runs in the
same vein um pastor Pastor you have
anything well we're not at the end of
the thousand of the 7,000 years we're
somewhere uh close to the end of the
6,000 years correct and basically um JN
Andrews when he was alive wrote a series
of articles that appeared in the review
and Herald the title of the Articles was
God's great week where Jan Andrews who
was a great scholar I think that he was
probably the greatest scholar that the
Seventh Day Adventist Church had at that
time
um came to the conclusion that uh world
history is going to last 6,000 years and
then the 7,000th Millennium is the
Millennium of Revelation chapter 20 um
it's based on conjecture somewhat
because the Bible does have a cycle of
seven when it comes to the week seven
days and then the Sabbath it has also
yes uh six days and then the seventh day
of the Sabbath yes and and then you have
uh the sabatical cycle which is uh six
years and then the seventh year and also
the Bible has the jubile year which is
497 and then the 50th is the Jubilee
year but there is no explicit place in
the Bible that applies 6,000 years in
the 7,000th
Millennium and uh and so it's based
somewhat on conjecture uh nobody knows
exactly when the 6,000 years came to to
an end or if they have come to an end um
the idea is that we need to be ready all
the time and not speculate about the
times and the seasons not set dates for
certain events for example there are
those that saying that that are saying
that Jesus is going to come in the year
2031 MH uh you know God has not called
upon us to set dates like that because
people get excited then the date goes by
and they're worse off than before and so
God's has said that we're in the waiting
time let's be ready every minute of
every day and not set dates for any
prophetic event because there will be no
more dates after 1844 yes amen yes amen
yeah we've come to the end of time as
far as date setting is concerned now now
we did in that last time we looked at
this question uh deal with some of Ellen
White's statements saying 6,000 years
ago she mentions that and I think we
explained that that was not a hard
figure uh it's a it's a a general figure
um it's not
6,000 as opposed to 601 but it's a
general figure and so this I think Falls
in there's a pattern of sevens and seven
being complete so it's not pulled out of
the air that these numbers are there but
to to lock down on these numbers in some
sort of attempt to try to prefigure when
chis is going to come or get a little
leg up on that that's using it the wrong
way and I think that's what you were you
were in toning Pastor thank you for that
man all righty um we go to South Africa
now and um this is coming from Anonymous
so this time we get the country we don't
get a name um but thank you for for
writing us this is uh fairly lengthy but
let's just take a look at it we'll walk
our way through it again coming from
South Africa I'd like to keep my name
private we care this is from a
19-year-old in in in uh uh from Africa
fairly young person uh let's see is it
sinful to engage in interracial marriage
specifically those of blacks and whites
and of course coming from South Africa I
could see some of the the the animous
for this particular question Ellen Way
has a few statements speaking against it
from the
context uh it had nothing to do with the
races as individuals of rather the
societal Stig
stigmatization of the mixing of both
racist back then racism was Heavy in the
United States and children uh who were
uh who are mixed were disadvantage sure
but today this tension of racism is not
really as strong as before interracial
marriages are actually encouraged and
not really a thing that catches people
off God as in her day obviously racism
is still there there there's always
going to be a few exceptions and
instances unless Satan takes a sabatical
which you will not certain things always
is going to be stigmatized on this side
of of Africa on this side of Africa we
have people of European descent they are
white ethnicity not mixed and are and
are of African nationality and
intermarriages at least in my country uh
are not really a big deal or a bad thing
if anything they are praised um I'm glad
to hear that uh having been to South
Africa and um knowing of the apartate
system which dominated their politics
for so many many years that um this is
not a big deal uh anymore in his
particular country but anything from
your heart Pastor or Pastor Salazar yeah
it's true that Ellen White did frown on
interracial marriages uh in her day but
she has a statement where she manifests
great wisdom and I'd like to read that
statement uh it's in volume one of
selected messages page
57h where she wrote regarding the
testimonies nothing is
ignored nothing is cast
aside but time and place must be
considered nothing must be done
untimely so when we read Ellen White's
writings we have to take into account
the time and the place yes right in her
day there was great stigmatization mhm
of interracial marriages
and the couple actually suffered because
of the pressure of society because of
the intercial marriage these days it's
much more common to see uh whites
married with blacks uh I personally
married a Hispanic that's another race
right and uh we get along fine of course
my parents were missionaries I grew up
in Latin America so I'm by cultural
besides bilingual but uh you know what
existed in the days of Ellen White is no
longer an issue today uh I might provide
a parallel to that Ellen White condemned
the purchase and use of a
bicycle now people read that today they
say this lady was crazy I mean why can't
you buy a bike and why can't you ride a
bike well because we have to take into
account time and place when she wrote
those statements right in her day the
bicycles were just coming into existence
and people were mortgaging all of their
goods to purchase a bike and they were
competing with their neighbors and they
were they were involved in races where
people were getting hurt right and so at
that time in place that was very
appropriate now you know we might say
that U we should not buy a
Lamborghini you know because the
principle would apply course so what we
need to do is take into account the time
and the place and apply the
principle not necessarily the specific
Council of that
time well said and also you know Pastor
there is this verses in James chapter 2
vers 8 and nine and I want to sort of
read especially because we're living in
a time where the Lord has given us so
much light and as you've mentioned today
things such as inter interracial
marriages are not seen anymore as
something that's wrong or something that
is uh against the desires of the
families I mean now it's encouraged and
I know I have plenty of friends who have
been married in international marriages
and and they have wonderful families and
so there is this verse here that I think
that as we are approaching you know the
end of time we need to really start
truly coming to that concept of you know
true love for others and it says there
in verse 8 if you if you fulfill the
Royal law according to the scriptures
thou shall love thy neighbor as thyself
ye do well you know of course God wants
us to love one another right and then
verse n says but if you have respect to
persons we commit sin and are convicted
or convinced of the law of transgressors
so if we you know if we are have a
problem with
someone that is from a different you
know race marrying someone else and
there's true love in that we should be
happy about that instead of looking at
them as you know they're doing something
wrong and I think that the sin if
there's any sin it would be for from the
other aspect now those that reject the
you know the aspect of of loving really
showing love to anyone as there's no
respect of persons by from the Lord you
know that he doesn't he doesn't have a a
preference or anything like that you
know if God sees that way we should also
see that way I think that's what I would
suggest today maybe a little radical but
that's truly what I think the love of
God should be flowing in our lives and
we should really Embrace everybody
anyone you know the bottom line the
principle involved here uh is expressed
by the Apostle Paul in Acts 17 ahh uh
vers
24 and through
26 God who made the world and everything
in it since he is Lord of Heaven and
Earth does not dwell in temples made
with hands nor is he worshiped with
men's hands as though he needed anything
since he gives to all life breath and
all things and now comes the key verse
and he has made from one blood mhm every
nation of men to dwell on all the face
of the Earth and has determined their
appoint pre-appointment times in the
boundaries of their dwellings bottom
line is we all have the same blood we
all descend from Adam and Eve right and
therefore because we all have the same
blood because we descend from Adam and
Eve why in principle could there not be
interracial
marriages if the the black person the
white person all have the same blood
exactly the problem is with our
prejudice the problem is with our bias
you know and even Peter after the day of
Pentecost was biased right you know the
Apostle Paul had to rebuke him to his
face we all know about the story of the
sheet that came down with the unclean
animals and and uh and so on but but
Peter grew in his understanding after
that experience he said God made men
from All Nations one he created all and
so the principle is that there is no
room for Christians to be racists
absolutely because we're all in the same
boat we all came from the same place
absolutely amen well done you know all
three of us have something in common uh
we are all married to
Latinas well I'm the only Latino here
but you're the only Latino I I Shar
something with pastor bordon and then he
has he has it over me because I have
neither bicultural nor nor bilingual but
I'm married to a Latina and we get along
where we get along well you know real
well uh very well yeah we get along well
and um um I remember writing an article
for the evidence review year years ago
about a a young black student was going
to an exclusive School Upstate New York
whose kidneys failed and nobody in his
family was a match and the match the the
person they found was a perfect match
was his his teacher uh he was a black
kid from New York City she is a a a
white woman from upstate New York
perfect match I think it's seven antigen
mat perfect match she gave him a kidney
uh so I wrote that story down because
his family was Adventist um and they got
along very very very well that kidney to
this day is functioning well you know so
it butches your point all of One blood
so there's no no reason why two people
who love each other there are going to
be some pressures uh but um uh if Christ
is at the center of the marriage they
going to be a lot of successes
interestingly enough all of my mother's
Brothers married Caucasians all of them
they're all my mother is from Canada so
this happened in Canada and this is a
two generations ago wow but all of them
so I have a lot of bir cousins all my
first cousins are are bous all their
mothers are white their fathers are
black so it works and I've seen it work
in my own uh in my own family and my own
life you know I um I just said to Melvin
this morning uh he does our programming
programs the people who come to do uh
presentations here um I gave him a big
hug he's African-American and I said
Melvin were brothers of the same
father and sure you appreciated that
praise the lord we both did yeah I know
and you know there's the thing as we're
coming closer to the end of time God
wants his people to be of one Accord
really to have that love it doesn't
matter what culture you were brought up
what you know raise you are off God
really seeking for a people that are
united that go beyond that and become
one in Christ that love that Unity is
still not there because we have still
are holding to these Prejudice views and
I believe God is this you know letting
us know that uh it is time now to truly
Embrace and love one another without any
you know uh reserves basically truly
show the love of God and and be United
with him and that way you won't have
these problems you won't have these
worries about you know separate uh
segregation or that kind of thing in in
in God's people the first time I went to
public school was in the sixth grade
before then I went to Blind school I was
blind uh and my sight improved enough
for me to be mainstreamed and go to
public school uh at about age 11 uh yeah
sixth grade is my first time in public
school uh when you're blind you didn't
know who was that other person leading
you around you know you could maybe tell
by the name uh but there's no way to
know and uh you find that people depend
on people and as the song says people
need people uh and when you're blind it
doesn't matter is can the person help me
can they assist me and that's all that
counts amen amen amen all righty uh well
done and um we go now to Brian nees I
know this n IE VES because I had a
family of nees when I was pastoring in
New York uh and interestingly enough the
baby was Brian I just wonder if perhaps
this could be that same Brian it could
be Nas too exactly yeah it could be Nas
Florida yeah it could be yeah mine is
were from the island of Antiga and they
were nees so it could be neas that's
very very true wasn't it that just just
that they mispronounced the last name in
Ana they wouldn't think
so I'm sure they like these uh here we
go I am deeply confused by one uh by the
unforgivable sin if I'm not mistaken it
is known as the rejection of the Holy
Spirit I have recently chosen to Res
surrender my life to Christ and I thank
some TV in particular well praise the
Lord amen because of the choices I've
made in the past knowing the truth and
disobeying and even hearing the spirit
and choosing to look away I feel like a
dead man walking the thought of those
choices from the past haunts me although
I have seen many changes in my life over
a short period I can't shake the feeling
that maybe I won't be forgiven it brings
me to a state of Anguish to think that
I've reached a point of Eternal loss is
it too late for me can you shed some
light on this grave sin now he's talking
about the unpardonable sin but his his
issue is really something else uh that's
that's not the the part his issue is
that Satan is is and I use this term my
mother has used washing his face with
his past he needs to get out from under
the condemnation of his past and um um
I'll let you gentlemen take a stab at
this because I know you're you're
chopping at the bit I've got two texts I
want to get at before we before we end
this but let's let's deal with what his
real issue is it's not really the
unpardonable sin no it's it's it's
Freedom From Your Past things and and
believing that God is powerful enough to
do what he says he's going to do that is
the real issue who wants to take it
first pastor
Pastor well I could uh mention something
from the word of God that I think needs
to for him to understand I think like
you said part of his problem is
accepting the for forgiveness of Christ
or the fact that he has been forgiven
and that there is still Grace and I
believe that we have to be very careful
uh to not think that we have stepped so
much beyond the truth that God cannot
forgive us or bring us back the story of
the prodical son is an example of
someone like Brian who has understood
his mistake realized that he was away
from God he did things that he should
not have done and it's now time to go
back to the father
and he has done that has come back to
the Lord and has to accept that his love
and his mercy and his grace forgives and
covers his sins and this is where I
would like to mention this verse that it
says there in Hebrews chapter uh you
know uh 10 verse
16 and 17 he says this is the Covenant
that I will make with them after those
days said the Lord I will put my laws
into their hearts and in their minds
will I grite them and their sins and
iniquities will I remember no more there
is a promise here there's a blessing
that Brian I encourage him to to accept
by faith that as you have come back to
the Lord he he is promising you that he
was wants to write his law in his heart
his law in his mind and once he's doing
that his previous sins his iniquities
will be completely forgotten by the Lord
he will remember them not anymore and
through that experience he can be
confident that God has forgiven him that
there is no worry in his heart that you
know God will not see him as a new
person and as new creature in Christ and
this is why it says there also um you
know verse 22 let us draw near with a
True Heart in full Assurance of Faith
having our hearts sprinkled from the
evil conscience and our bodies washed
with pure water so as you come to Christ
he's promising to cleanse your mind even
that that memory that you have of the
sin that has been you know so terrible
that he did that he was involved with
God is willing to purge that from your
life from your heart and he promises to
do that and so I think that this should
encourage him to to believe that as he
has come back to the Lord his arms are
open wide to bless him forgive him and
give him his
grace I think that the problem
is that uh he doesn't really have faith
in God's promises yes that's see
forgiveness has nothing to do with the
way you feel mhm because if if
forgiveness had anything to do with the
way you feel nobody would go
successfully through the time of trouble
when Satan is going to try to convince
you that your sins were too great God
could not forgive them so what's the use
of being faithful in the time of trouble
God has a verse which probably I'm
pretty sure that CA has in his notes as
well because we you know even though we
don't compare notes we're usually on the
same page right in 1 John
1:9 you want to read it um yes being
that it was your
inspiration read it first
John one it's a Divine promise in first
John 1 19 indeed it is and I I I could
quote but I like to read s up next say
um he who oh 1 john9 I'm in 29 if if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
to forgive us our sins and to cleanse us
from all unrighteousness take it to the
bank yeah am you have to believe amen
believe it because not because you feel
it but because God says so absolutely
you know you have the experience of
Jacob you know Jacob he stole the
birthright from his brother and he lied
to his father he deceived his father had
to leave home for 20 years on the way uh
to laan's house
uh he had that uh wonderful dream of uh
the latter right uh reaching from Heaven
to Earth and Angels ascending and
descending on the ladder uh God was
telling Jacob hey I haven't shut the
communication between you and Heaven
down it's still open because uh Jacob
had repented of his sin and yet for 20
years Jacob could not forgive himself
could forgive himself and that was the
struggle at penel uh where he struggled
with the angel said I will not let you
go until you bless me unless you bless
me what Jacob is saying I need the
assurance that I've been forgiven yes
well he had already been forgiven 20
years before but he could not forgive
himself the biggest problem is we don't
forgive ourselves right God forgives us
but we're not able to embrace the
Forgiveness because somewhat we lack
faith in God's promises amen well done
pastors I just wanted to add Romans
chapter 8 verse1 which is a very
familiar text one of my favorites there
is now therefore no condemnation to
those who are in Christ Jesus so is
you're walking with Christ you believe
in Christ you feel the guilt of your
sins but you're not condemned by Christ
because he has forgiven your sins and is
cleansing you from all unrighteousness
rely on that believe in that amen trust
that God can do and is doing what he
says he will do for the world and for
you personally as a child of God go free
uh the song says and um trust in the
Lord that he will save you and that he
will keep you until the day that he
delivers you from this life to a brand
new life in Christ Jesus amen well
gentlemen again our time has slipped
into eternity allow me please in closing
to wish you both Grace and peace through
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ we'll
see you again soon bye-bye and God
[Music]
bless